now you mentioned bolder than your
school yes this is so sweet
I don't I haven't seen this picture
before this is you in school and you've
sort of changed a lot and not changed at
all this is you John in there what
you're giving well that was a play
called fry bacon and fry bunga's and
Elizabeth and play written about
Shakespeare's time and I was playing the
young heroine you don't quite see the
boy in the sixth form I'm madly in love
with Jude on to try and find him Bryan
those quite handsome that one I don't
know
I mean it's a good game but I'll get it
yeah he might be just out of shop I
think yes dear and people obviously get
very excited when you go on tour in
places rather well you've got a blue
plaque haven't you most people have to
die to get a blue plaque did you got a
number of blue people have yeah I got
one on the house where I was born in
Burnley but I I did go and visit it on
my second and the visit to Berlin
because we left when I was two myself
and I think they put it on the wrong
house no this other one is in Liverpool
I think all leads
it's live but we thought it was Leeds
but I think it's Liverpool yes yes well
what was their doing there
I think I can tell you what you were
doing there I can tell you what you're
doing there see a Miguel had sat here on
Table five and enjoyed a jacket potato
and a latte
[Applause]
where do you know where that is it sits
on the University campus Oh found yes
was it a nice potato Liverpool's looking
gorgeous these days since they've done
it up oh when I was a kid and it was a
dangerous and dirty and dank place pre
beetles everything but now of course
it's it's spanking it's terrific
oh it's beautiful now yes in the show
obviously you'll be you know as you said
you'll be talking about Shakespeare and
doing scenes but you'll be also telling
stories about your life and I know
people you've worked with there's a
story
danger against trying to ask me to tell
another Maggie Smith story no every time
I see her she said you've not been doing
me again
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you